we've had one or two comments and people
asking the questions about how how easy
or how difficult it must be to D
anonymize data so it's a problem isn't
it absolutely I mean I think a few years
ago 2013 there was a published study
where they took 1.5 million phone
records for in a small European country
probably Belgium from that one of the
authors and they randomly selected four
locations they would sort of loaded the
nearest cell tower and from that they
could uniquely identify we identified
95% of the database and by choosing 11
data points they got 100% they were able
to uniquely identify who these people
were and underlying that is you know
some simple observations about people
tend to live somewhere work somewhere
and even those two data points are
probably enough to uniquely identify
folks and then you can look for
everything else tagged with that and you
can probably track people around so it's
actually lots of examples of where what
seems like a large amount of random data
is not because it actually contained
within it it's huge amount of structure
it's always difficult to imagine how one
can anonymize the data set and it's
create a data set that has records which
are associated with an individual where
we essentially just delete the name or
replace it with some code at a random
number it's very difficult to defend
that against all possible future attacks
because someone could turn up with
another data set which includes I don't
know three or four of the fields that
are the same as the anonymous data set
but with a name associated with it and
then by correlating those two data sets
together you'll get a set may not be a
one-off but you might get a set of
candidates of I think the following four
people the following four anonymous
records could be this person because
they
on some other fields and then you could
start saying well let's look at them in
the enormous record what the other
fields are and maybe there's something
entertaining or scurrilous about that
our privacy in vsf that people want
wouldn't want to know and this is that
this is very much the attack we saw and
the the film rating database were people
rated films with their names on them and
then an anonymized data set was
published with so and so rented all
these you know this anonymous person
rented all these films give us a better
recommendation algorithm for them so
there's a big record of all these
anonymous identifiers but of course you
watch a film and you write a review so
even though this set of people who had
published their reviews had not reviewed
every film they watched the fact that
you could correlate they obviously
rented these movies and then made their
reviews probably shortly afterwards
caused you to be able to take that and
publicly identify and associated with
all the movies they've watched including
the ones perhaps they didn't want people
to know about the classic is politicians
getting you know caught watching at an
old content that's very embarrassing for
them and the thing is that if someone
says here's anonymous data where the
records still contain all the data and
it's associated with an individual or
maybe we'd call that soon organized it
will never protect against all possible
future databases that might arise with
real names associated with them and
that's the very that's the problem with
the you know D anonymization is a threat
that's always there so that's a
fundamental problem if what you have is
a record per person no matter what you
do I think there's another there's
another thing as well which it perhaps
mentioned in that space sometimes the
way in which people choose the identity
anonymous identifier is pretty pretty
dire really so New York cab company
decided to publish all the pick up an
awful points of all the yellow cabs and
they anonymized the badge number of the
driver now in fact there are just aren't
that many badges so someone computed all
the possible hash file
of the badges and hence you're able to
just invert the whole thing and so
you're able to read enta Phi because
there was an algorithmic means to
produce the anonymous identifier in fact
what you really want to do is just if
you do want to do this you really just
need to your death generate a random
number do not make it a hash value when
the space of values is not that large
brute force attacks it's a bit like
cryptography you know it was really hard
it took a lot of work to break enigma
during the Second World War right but
these days your average PC would crack
it in seconds if laughs so it's slowly
increasing you know processing part
that's available and the fact that we
have GPU cards with hundreds of GPUs on
them or even more so cryptographic
accelerators as we see in some other and
some of the modern processors if you
have all of that those engines there
then the challenge is that you you
simply have to keep making the problem
harder and harder so the next thing you
could try to do is say well why don't we
do the sort of techniques that the
Census adopt which is they don't publish
per postcode data because even that's a
too fine grid they they an aggregate the
data out such that the statistics that
they publish are at the levels of you
know hundreds of thousands of people and
that doesn't completely prevent
re-identification but it certainly
starts to make it substantially harder
and some of the some of the times like
cryptography the mission is to make it
substantially harder and to put it
beyond reasonable computational
resources after all all cryptography
falls into that category it's not like
you cannot break cryptography you just
do brute force just making a thousand
years but remember what was predicted to
take a thousand years in 1945 he's no
you know milliseconds on a modern
computer so he always got a factor in
that so that the issue
is quite difficult to make this for
people to read enta fie and of course
essentially you know when you get down
to it this is what intelligence agents
would be doing for years I mean they'll
be looking at all sorts of random
sources of information and understanding
how they all correlate together so even
when you are aggregated it may still be
possible to to re-identify within that
group and it has to be not just that you
aggregate to within say a hundred people
or something it also has to be that
there can be no population of I don't
know less than ten or twenty in that
group I mean my son was asked to fill in
a survey at school and they said oh it's
all completely anonymous and they asked
for his postcode no he sat at dinner
long enough listening to me go on about
this repeatedly and he simply repeat
then put in a bogus postcode and he said
well that's ridiculous because there's
only two of us kids at school of a
school age on this street and I said no
it's worse than that son he lives around
the corner that's a different postcode
because the street name
he said there's precisely one fifteen
year old child on this street so it was
uniquely identifying and something that
someone thought well that will be fine
you know it wasn't because actually
although there are a number of people
live in our street there's only one
there was only one fifteen year olds at
the time so it was uniquely identifying
so it's a complex problem even when you
aggregate to try to anonymize because
you've got to think about you know is it
a unique sample within that aggregate in
which case it's still a problem so you
find that the people have been doing
this for years which is people like the
Office of National Statistics they have
tried and tests tested mechanisms where
they've evaluated the risk of the
identification and that's why they
publish things like census data and the
data that they publish every month that
comes out of the ons they're very
careful about them now this is something
that actually has become recently I've
noticed some very interesting to lots of
companies who are trying to deal with
data protection the new general data
protection regulation coming in in the
where they're saying well what on earth
could we possibly do because we were
lied to keep these synonymous records
but what does that mean and I heard a
very sensible colleague from a large
company say well why don't we do what
the ONS does because they've had a
hundred years experience on this and
they seem to know what they're doing and
surely we can carry the same level of
risk as they can so it is a very subtle
problem but like most of these things in
the same way that I would simply say
that there is no cryptography that is
completely bulletproof it's a question
of just how difficult is it to crack the
crypto when it comes to anonymization
the question is how difficult is it to
break the anonymization and he's simply
applying new interesting and different
perspectives and different data assets
to the original one you know things that
the original creator never thought about
will be the attacks so our mission
always has to be simply to make it at
least provably challenging
computationally to do and that's and it
should personally maybe some genius is
gonna quote someone that really does
work but I've yet to see anyone who
would believe that we truly can
anonymize in the same way that other
than one-time patterns in cryptography
we can't do a crypto that's not open to
brute force attack
that really matter but they started
discriminating against that and a bit
tolerant was the classic were lots of
people were discriminate against
BitTorrent but then of course it turns
out that many people were using
BitTorrent for perfectly legitimate
reasons yes there were
BitTorrent file sharing and there still
is plenty of it around